My next guest has appeared in such films
as "Soul Plane" and
"John Tucker Must Die."
Now she can be seen in the
new movie, "The Grudge 2,"
let's take a look.
(wood creaking)
(eerie music)
(girl crying)
(wood creaking)
(girl screaming)
Please!
(screaming)
Oh, man.
(audience applause)
That's pretty intense.
Please welcome Arielle Kebbel!
You know, all the time on this show,
we're showing clips of
like a frightening movie,
and it's not that frightening.
That's a really scary
piece of film right there.
Well thank you, I'm glad it's scary.
Your scream is very impressive.
Thank you.
That's a good scream.
Did you know you could scream like that
when you got this part?
Not quite like that.
I've never quite really had
a ghost coming at me before.
[Conan] Right.
So that was the first time for that.
But no, I grew up in Orlando, Florida,
home of every theme park-
[Conan] Right.
and you know,
before I was doing TV and film,
I spent a lot of time as an
extra, riding roller coasters.
As an extra?
Why would they need
extras on roller coasters?
Because not everyone
actually wants to go on them
(Conan laughing)
like in the commercials.
Really? So you were-
Sorry Disney, Universal,
and Sea World.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So like for commercial or something,
they'd put you on a rollercoaster.
Oh yeah.
And they make you ride it like 32 times.
[Conan] Right.
In fact, they only stop
if you're puking or feel
like you might puke.
[Conan] Right, right.
So my friends and I,
I was like 14 at the time,
so we thought it was really cool
if we actually started
feeling sick riding it,
so we'd try and outdo each other.
We'd ride it like 10 times at a time.
But yeah, that's where, you know...
The camera, you get more camera time
if you look scared and
you've got, you know,
your teeth are showing
and you're loud.
And so I let loose screaming
back then and it paid off.
That's great.
Yeah, 'cause I was...
That's one of the things
that grabbed my attention
when we were watching these clips today
and just you, that's an amazing scream.
You can use that, you know?
Thank you.
Yeah.
If I could scream like that,
I'd be doing it all the time.
Like down the streets
of New York?
My scream does not impress.
Mine is more like, "No!"
You know?
(audience laughs)
Or like, "Ah!"
Ah, look out!
You know?
It's free turn of the century.
It's not good.
Beware!
You should be in "Grudge 3."
Yeah, yeah-
They'd love that.
that would be great, yeah.
Me, hiding from the monster.
No, ghost, go away, ah!
Please, ghost, flee!
(audience laughs)
Am I pronouncing your name right?
It's "Arielle."
Is that right?
Arielle.
Arielle Kebbel.
And you actually got "Kebbel" right too.
How do you mess up "Kebbel?"
It's K-E-B-B-L-E, it's not like,
"Kooblah? Kahblah?"
You know what?
You might want to talk to some people
because they've messed it up.
You're one of the first
that's gotten the right.
I'm amazed at how many
people over the years,
when I was a kid especially,
"Conan," it just always seemed like,
"Well, that's pretty obvious."
"Connan?"
"Connan," "Cronan,"
"Queenan."
"O'Breen?"
"O'Brain?"
Well, no. Everyone knows
"O'Brien," it's like...
(Conan laughs)
(audience laughs)
Sorry.
It's like the only name
in Ireland, you know?
Okay, I haven't been there.
They had one name. That was it.
So...
You grew up in Florida,
now you live in Los Angeles.
I do.
Do you enjoy living in Los Angeles?
Is it an adjustment from Florida?
I love it. There's still the palm trees.
There's still the ocean, so that's cool.
I gotta tell you,
Florida does not have
the traffic that the 405
has in LA.
The traffic in Los Angeles
has gotten terrible.
Oh, unbelievable.
But I think I figured out
a way to deal with it.
[Conan] Oh, yeah?
Okay. Well, it kind of
started not so long ago.
I used to do this thing
where if I wanted something,
or didn't get my way, or got my way,
I would bark like a dog.
And so my...
I'm just going to nod, like, of course.
(audience laughs)
(Arielle laughs)
You mean like you're at a restaurant
and they bring you mashed
potato, but there's no gravy,
and you asked for gravy you're like...
(barking like a dog)
Oh!
Like that kinda thing?
I don't have rabies, no.
Oh. (laughs)
That's the dog I would do
it'd have foam coming out the mouth...
(Conan growling)
That's great, thanks! Argh!
I'd get a fake paws and wave 'em around.
No, no, no, it's not that bad.
It's just, I would, it's kinda like a...
(squeaky barking)
Oh,
that's pretty good too,
so it's a little dog.
Yeah, and it's kinda like a...
(high-pitched barking)
(dog begging)
(audience laughs)
(Arielle laughs)
This is scarier than the clip somehow.
(all laugh)
Now I'm afraid.
Apparently,
(Conan laughing)
that's what my boyfriend said,
I didn't know that.
You do this to your boyfriend?
I do, but this is, so
this is how it started,
so for awhile, I think he probably thought
it was really weird,
but he kind of,
I guess you got used to it
and now, we've done this thing,
we both do it now, so he's gonna kill me,
but when you're in traffic,
it's more healing than any yoga,
than any drink, than anything you can do-
Right and you're getting tense.
You're getting tense,
someone cuts you off,
you've got that urge to just yell at 'em
or just flip 'em off or whatever.
Instead, you roll down your
window and you just go...
(growls ferociously)
Okay, that would get you killed
so fast.
(audience laughing)
You know that, don't you?
To me,
that seems worse than
giving someone the finger
or waving a gun at them, going...
(growling fiercely)
Think about it.
Think about it!
You've got your head out the window,
and someone's totally
expecting you to yell at them
and instead you just growl like (growls)
and they don't know, they're like...
[Conan] That's so weird.
They kinda twitch a bit
and they don't know whether
to laugh or cry, you know?
I do a variation, which
is I hiss like a cat,
I go (hisses) like that.
See, that's a little more scary to me,
but that's not loud enough.
If you're in traffic,
they have to hear you.
You got to get it like right here, like...
(growling aggressively)
That'd be so weird if we had ever met
like at a singles club and you were like
(vicious barking)
and I was like (hissing)
It was this weird,
kinda crazy kinda-
We're like
petting each other.
I wouldn't do that.
Well, actually I would do that,
yeah.
Yeah, see?
I know, there you go.
Like, I draw the line
there. That's getting weird.
Okay.
What we were doing before
was perfectly normal.
Well, "The Grudge 2" is in theaters now.
Today, Friday the 13th.
Today, so check it out.
I hope we scare you.
And Arielle Kebbel,
thank you so much.
[Arielle] Thank you so much.
Nice hissing and growling at you.